the impact of Friday's decision was
Swift and in some states with so-called
trigger laws in effect abortion clinics
closed down and stop providing Services
almost immediately Jackson Women's
Health Organization the Mississippi
clinic at the center of the Supreme
Court case and the state's only abortion
provider is expected to shut down within
weeks Omar villafranca is in Dallas on
how this decision already is being felt
Omar good morning
good morning there were protests here in
Dallas and in the states across the
South where those trigger laws went into
effect to give an idea of the impact if
a woman here in Dallas wanted to get an
abortion to get to the nearest clinic
she would have to travel more than 350
miles two states away to Wichita Kansas
with the country's abortion laws now up
to the states Arkansas went into action
yesterday for me this is a turning point
for our nation
since Roe versus Wade was decided the
states that desired to protect unborn
life have been prohibited from doing so
in Oklahoma any medical staff performing
abortions could face prison time
Oklahoma is one of eight states where
the Court's ruling triggers abortion
bans with no exceptions for rape or
incest God did this in Louisiana the
last abortion clinic closed down
yesterday and what you have prayed for
is to make death for women easier
because you don't allow them access to
good Medical Care throughout the country
abortion activists say that poor women
many of color will be hit hardest you're
basically sentencing black women to to
death because already you already were
dying in childbirth Missouri
congresswoman Corey Bush I was able to
pick up the Yellow Pages and find the
provider when I was 18 after a rape that
happened when I was 17. and get the
services that I needed activists and
some Governors are doubling down in an
already divided country we are gonna
fight like hell to keep Washington a
pro-choice state Washington state has 40
abortion clinics neighboring Idaho has
three which could close after the
state's Governor saluted the Supreme
Court's decision Washington expects a
nearly 400 percent increase in abortion
patients nearly 60 percent already come
from Idaho with the action that I'm
taking here California's governor
quickly signed legislation yesterday to
protect out-of-state women who come for
abortion extraordinary leadership
it's worth noting the landmark Roe
versus Wade case started here in Dallas
Henry Wade was the former Dallas County
district attorney well now the current
Dallas D.A and several others across the
state of Texas say they understand the
law but they will not make Prosecuting
abortions a top priority Dana
all right Omar thank you